a liberal feminist easts side bisexual
gal has gone viral on Tik Tok
for relating her shock her awe at her
own reaction to going on a date with a
bro I went on a date this week and I
felt the feminism leaving my body I live
on the east side of LA and if you don't
know what that means it's sort of like
the artsier part of La you know it's
it's people say it's like Brook in New
York like so I go on dates with a lot of
men and women who you know live over
here there's always a negotiation about
who pays and that's great I like to pay
for people all that but what I will
say is that I sort of fell into going on
a date with the most guys guy I've ever
been on a date with and he's from West
West you know Santa Monica he's a bro
right a GU guy is usually not my type
like I cannot remember the last time
that I went on a date with like a
straight Bros bro you know what I'm
saying but it befell me it befell me in
an organic fashion so I'm on this date
with this guy and the thing about a
guy's guys is he's putting his card down
he's paying for everything and I really
just it sort of activated something
feral in me I'm not going to lie we went
to like another bar and he went he was
going to go to the bathroom so I was
getting prepared to pay for our drinks
cuz he's been paying all night of course
I'm going to pay for the next round but
as he's going to leave for the bathroom
he turns to me and he hands me his
credit card and he goes here's my card
get us
whatever it might be time for me to get
away from all these you know liberal
snowflakes on the east
side I love it I love this video I love
her take there's a little touch of irony
here when she uses that phrase at the
end these liberal snowflakes but that
little touch of irony is speaking to a
big truth and she's is actually feeling
it and reality remains
undefeated love it this is the this is
the consolation for conservatives the
whole culture is against us the
principalities and powers and spiritual
wickedness and high places that rule
this world they are all turned against
us all the time but here's but reality
is still there there's still an order to
the cosmos there is still Justice there
is actually and truth and goodness and
Beauty are not overwhelmed they are not
over shadowed
reality remains undefeated I love it
think about this video some people are
attacking her some very misguided
conservatives are attacking this poor
girl I think I find her very
Charming but they're attacking her
because all she's saying she's happy
about is that he paid for the date she's
not saying she liked the conversation
she's not saying he was good-looking
she's not she just she liked that he
paid for dinner and when he went to hit
the head passed her his credit card and
said hey could you order the next round
of drinks get
whatever oh she's just a gold digger no
no no this is a poor girl who deserves
our sympathy and encouragement and she's
typical in this culture there are a lot
of podcasts out there most of those
podcasts are people talking about their
intimate lives complaining about how
America's racist or how religion is evil
now outside of the daily wire it is
tough to find creative handsome podcasts
that are both enjoyable and intellectual
and extremely charismatic and even sexy
some would say well luckily there's a
great new Catholic podcast that I just
heard about the podcast is called
breakfast and is the perfect mix of
entertaining and spiritual Catholic
content breakfast explains the Catholic
faith through the prism of food drink
landmarks and architecture the Catholic
faith is so interwoven in our culture
that we often don't even realize it the
word breakfast for example comes from
Catholics breaking the fast after
morning Mass did you know Sushi tempura
has its roots in the Catholic faith I
didn't know that or how champagne was
actually created by a Catholic monk
named Dom Perino I assumed it was made
by a priest named father Cristal but I
was wrong it's it's a monk named Dom
Peron the shows creators saw the need
for a podcast that is engaging and
accessible to everyone of any faith or
none at all breakfast is not just a
random assortment of Catholic related
facts it covers hard-hitting top topics
it will make you Ponder the important
questions each episode of breakfast is
around 20 minutes long super easy
download it right now on Apple Spotify
or wherever you get your podcasts right
now go to genucell.com today there is a
lot to be stressed about during the
Christmas season stress and lack of
sleep can easily cause those pesky under
eye bags good news is you never have to
worry about that when you have genell
skincare from now until Christmas
genell's most popular package has a
special discount just for our listeners
at jus cell.com
KW treat yourself and your loved ones to
the absolute best skincare in the world
those troubling forehead wrinkles Fine
Lines skin redness and sagging jaw line
will disappear right before your eyes
with jus cell's most popular collection
Jus cell promises immediate effect you
will see results in less than 12 hours
guaranteed or your money back Jus cell
made Christmas come early this year they
sent down a ton of products for the
entire office everyone is raving about
their under eye cream it works wonders
plus included in every most popular
package is your free high honic acid
serum for skin hydration and restoration
you deserve to look and feel your best
this Christmas season go to genucell.com
right now get this incredible holiday
discount every order instantly upgraded
to a free express shipping jus.com
kwes today could you imagine could you
imagine for the the normal people
listening to this
show how far our sexual relations have
fallen I don't mean you know Saucy stuff
I'm talking about actually how men and
women relate to to one another that this
woman for the first time in her life
perhaps had a guy buy her a drink and
she's floored by it this woman what
she's in her 20s I don't know how old
exactly a guy bought her a drink and she
can't get over it she has to take to the
internet to explain to the masses what
this unusual experience is
like this is Baseline stuff this guy did
not lay his coat out on a puddle for her
to walk over this guy did not send
flowers to her home or her office this
guy did not I don't even know if he
opened the door of the car he just
bought her some drinks and
dinner and she just melts of course she
melts this this whole
attitude you know I'm an easts side
feminist I live in Los FES La whatever
I'm hip and cool I'm kind of a lesbian
you know like I'm cool I was was cool in
college I'm I'm a lesbian like all all
of that goes away and she she's laughing
about it but of course it does it's not
even her fault she probably went to some
stupid liberal arts college that don't
actually doesn't actually teach you the
liberal arts that just encourages you to
like wear silly sweaters and date all
sorts of members of both sexes and study
grievance and then move to LA and become
whatever kind of artist she is okay she
had a disadvantage from the
beginning is this the first time she's
ever met some kind of Finance bro
wearing a a Patagonia zipup
vest with some kind of button-down
collar who who even has a credit card is
this this might be the first time that
she hasn't met some guy who's just you
know vaguely soy kind of Pumped full of
estrogen has an unkempt beard and asks
her to pay for dinner this is and so I
don't I don't knock her for it she's
discovered something new and you know
what she it's not that she's discovered
the Westside guy with a job and a line
of credit it's not just that she's
discovered a date what a date is
supposed to look like in the most basic
degree she's discovered reality just a
little T just a little hint of reality
in a culture that has heaped mud and
dirt and obscured reality she's just
seen like a little glimmer of it and
she's excited by that and I'm excited by
that too I encourage her that's great
keep going keep going
lady I'm I'm with you I'm cheering you
on man what a great clip that was now
whoa hold up ring that Bell subscribe to
the Michael Nolls YouTube channel and we
will see you next time